en plena campaña de vacunación en toda
la unión europea y con 7 millones de
personas inmunizadas la unión europea no
quiere ir ya por detrás del virus sin
saber qué atenerse por ello propone un
plan en que sea mucho más fácil atacar a
las nuevas variantes y evitar que todo
descarrile por ello la comisión europea
propone un plan en que sea mucho más
fácil hacer tests que sean capaces de
detectar con más facilidad las nuevas
variantes que sea mucho más fácil
también rastrear y por ello propone una
financiación adicional de 200 millones
de euros para su investigación también
propone que sea mucho más fácil aprobar
nuevas vacunas que el proceso de
autorización sea mucho más rápido además
las farmacéuticas que ya tengan vacunas
aprobadas pero que tengan nuevas
adoptadas al nuevo virus también será un
mecanismo muchísimo más fácil y ya no se
tendrá que pasar por todo el proceso
habitual como ya ocurre con la vacuna de
la gripe además todas las farmacéuticas
con nuevas vacunas tendrán que demostrar
plan
detallados sobre cómo va a ser su
producción de dosis y así evitar
sorpresas desagradables como la ocurrida
con astrazéneca en que finalmente sólo
podrá distribuir un 50 por ciento de las
vacunas inicialmente prometidas en
definitiva la unión europea quiere esta
vez ganar la batalla al virus y esta no
es la única buena noticia porque la
presenta de la comisión europea-
auslander legend hoy también ha
anunciado 300 millones de dosis
adicionales de la vacuna de moderna en
total la región podrá contar así con
2.600 millones de dosis